[Music]
sure okay can I hand you the camera
right now and have you asked me any
question anyway
sure okay so you want a sweet spot here
it's already recording I just put on my
face and push this button once it should
focus and whenever you're ready you can
ask me whatever you want okay so ask me
whatever you want and then you could ask
whenever you're ready you can make it
fun just not political okay all right so
your one question is
the anticipation is killing right that's
all I thought when you walked up to you
with that camera why are you doing this
I knew you're gonna ask that because the
last time people happy the same thing I
just want to share good stories and what
better way than to French random people
and ask them a random question why are
you here
just like in general like where's your
purpose in life as a human being
why are you dream I think my purpose in
life is the same as
everyone's purpose in life and that is
to just do good and
I think each individual's purpose is to
find the tool in
to do that
I'm glad that I think I finally found it
[Music]
like I was meant to do this I don't know
really cheesy but like ever since I
started this project that really feels
right and it feels like the two
that I need
you know you could
yeah yeah tell me a funny joke that you
know our joke that you've picked up a
long line since been here in goes my
little cousin told me when the other day
that I was good Oh
have you heard of the movie constipation
no it hasn't come out yet if you came I
got asked this the other day and I've
got to think about it more and but I
think the answer would stay the same and
that is I'd want to be any bird except
for a crow because I'd be able to fly
penny of their confidence to talk to
people like that every day oh my gosh I
don't I feel like I don't I'm so the
first day I did this project that was
really hesitant and
wasn't really scared the fear of
rejection yeah I'm just getting rejected
and just that I'll never get easy like
you every time I get rejected even like
the hundredth time or it's just as bad
as the first time yeah this just like if
you just keep going
so like say I get rejected by ten people
and then one person says yes that one
person makes me forget about the other
time yeah so yeah you just keep going
well my question for you is what is your
theory about zombies do they exist or do
they not easily it's not about zombies
honestly I don't get scared very often
like during scary movies but one of the
things that scares me the most are
zombies so I hope the demon exists I
don't think they exist but yeah I don't
I mean you see do you have an opinion on
it you see like everything zombies are
real and they're out there and they
aren't real one thing you change about
your life someone actually asked me that
yesterday and I said that I would change
the fact that I overthink things and
then I thought about it I overthought it
and and today I don't think I would
change anything because I think a part
of what makes me me is that I overthink
things and I wouldn't want to be a
different person what inspired you to
make films just like get into filmmaking
in general yeah I like what inspired you
to start YouTube I feel like there is so
many different ways to connect with
people and like get a message across
you can do it through music or do
written work or through photography and
I think that film brings them all
together and that's just so powerful to
me I feel like as a creator who likes to
share stuff like certain messages and
have people shift their views on certain
things for the better so yeah I think
it's just a really powerful tool to get
a good message across how would you
define consciousness oh jeez
okay it's good taking a minute because I
want to work this really good cuz I like
that question
so would you say that defining
consciousness would be along the same
lines of like when you feel like most
alive
I would say consciousness is what's my
question for you so okay
I think to me consciousness is being
fully outside of yourself and not in
your head at all
and I think I really like that question
because I feel like a lot of times I'm
not very conscious I feel like I'm in my
head most of the time overthinking stuff
and I think maybe that's why I'm having
such a hard time defining it because I
don't have much experience with it does
that make sense
sure who is the most famous person
you've ever asked this question to I've
been doing it for 30 days and I don't
think or do you find your hope in your
life where do I find my hope in my life
mm-hmm
can you rephrase that I'm not sure if I
really understood hey um maybe where did
your hope come from I'm okay okay that's
a good question I think I find hope and
other people like you guys like you I
just asked you to take my camera and ask
me a question which is really weird
but you're willing to do it and I think
where I find hope and that is that
you're helping me out right like even
though it's a really weird thing to do I
asked you to help me with the project
and you did it and everyday like 50
people do that for me it's hard not to
find hope in that
so yeah I find hoping just what's
happening right now if you were a color
what color would you be in one black for
sure
Black is just my favorite color and it's
mysterious and cool and what was the
biggest thing you could ask out for me
get me a million subscribers on native
million subscribers in YouTube yeah very
cool
all right let's break it up me all right
yeah did your mother know what you're
doing some right yes she does talking to
strangers yes she does
and what did she think about this she's
actually really proud oh good she's not
afraid no good well that's why you're so
great good luck with your project if you
can change the world
that's a really hard question I've
actually thought about asking this
question because that but I feel like
it's just so hard for someone to answer
it and you just put me on the spot you
take a minute
I think if I could change
it could be anything right like I can
get as creative as I want I would just
make it so everyone
understanding of Under
I feel like a lot of the problems that
we have
just like conflict is because
people feel like there's no really
relatability and
princes of culture or religion or at
like you just you feel like you can't
relate to them but if you just were
and like had a conversation with them
a lot of problems it's easy to go to war
with someone faceless but it's harder to
go to war
has a face
story so I think I would just make
everyone
and that would just would knock off a
lot of problems I think what would you
want to do if you were the President of
the United States one thing one thing
yeah my gosh this one doesn't have to be
the most important thing about what's
one thing you would like to do I'm in
charge of the United ID the one thing I
would do is get someone else to be the
president because that would make the
worst president that's fair enough I
would fire myself
yeah so thinking of your parents and
what values they instilled in you what
is one thing you would change if you
were a parent what are the different in
values you want to instill on your
children I've actually thought about
this a lot because
the thing that I would want to change
about the way my parents raised me is
the thing that I think I would find the
hardest to do and that is to tell your
kids no I was given everything that
women when I grew up I never we have to
work for anything and I think yeah we do
that I don't know if I'd be able to but
I think that's the one thing I just feel
like uh spoiled and I wouldn't want to
spoil my kids
I realize that
probably in college when I noticed a lot
of like my friends around me then it has
the same privileges as me my mom bought
me my first car I saw my friends like
working crazy to like pay for their cars
and it was really cool to me I thought
like I wish I'd done that but I think as
a parent you think that it's love giving
your child so much and it's really hard
to like step back and think like maybe
it's better for them not to give them
everything
I told my mom that I don't know she kind
of agreed but she's just like she
couldn't bring it herself like say no
yeah yeah that's the one thing I don't
know if I'd be able to do it because I
have a little cousins and I buy them
whatever they want if I were to talk to
three of your closest friends and I were
to ask them to describe you using three
words and three words only what three
words are they used to describe you
I'm sure one of them would say that I'm
a little crazy which i think is a good
thing okay I hope I hope one of them
would say that I'm kind
another word I think one of my friends
would use for sure for sure and is
obsessing because I just obsess over
certain things like certain projects
like the one I'm doing right now okay
yeah I think that's so kind obsessive
and crazy and crazy pretty good words
all right if it were some other
historical period of time where would
you see yourself being oh I think I'd
want to be alive when like the Olympics
started Wow and like I was like Greece
right yeah I think I'd want to be alive
when the Olympics started in Greece yeah
I hope that I'd be a part of it or
something what do you look for in a hair
stylist when you go to lunch
okay I don't go very often but when I do
and I used to have really short hair
when I would go is I was looking for
someone who would listen to what I had
to say take that into consideration but
also put their own knowledge into it as
well like if I told them that I wanted
to look a certain way and they knew that
I would look really ugly I would hope
that they would choose not to do it so
yeah so just a good balance if someone
who listens to what I want and also puts
their own touch on it as well
are you hairstylist I am so we've got a
good answer it was the great answers are
helping me learn
what people want from me okay cool yeah
I think that's a really good thing yeah
and you seem low maintenance so you want
a hairstyle you know do you feel
positive about the future for mankind or
do you think things will remain the same
or do you think they'll get worse I have
always been a positive person just for
like about anything I could be going
through the worst situation and always
find positivity in it somehow and it's
not that's not me bragging because
sometimes I think maybe it's not such a
good thing maybe it's not so realistic
sometimes but honestly especially with
what's happening right now just around
the world and
like just in general I feel like a lot
of people have been losing hope and they
don't really believe in the future for
mankind yeah we're all different like I
get 30 different answers every day but
somehow they they feel connected and
they're somehow touching and
inspirational and I feel like I hope it
gives people hope if you didn't name a
constellation what would you name it and
what with the shaky
[Music]
I want to say my name
one it is tough to just say my knee
I mean you seem like a cool person so I
would name a constellation what's your
name sir oh that's a cool company the
shape would be away
what is your favorite music my favorite
genre and music your favorite music you
can interpret that however you wish
music that makes me feel happy
that's my favorite if money were no
object where would you go and what would
you see I would go to Patagonia you're
familiar with it I heard of it I'm not
familiar with it
yeah it's known for like it's mountains
and nature and I'm really into nature
photography as well okay so it would be
good spot for that yeah everything was
paid for and I could go there for a
couple weeks does amazing okay awesome
what do you like about Balboa Park
that's a good question so for the
viewers who don't know this is where I'm
shooting the film right now and this is
where I shoot the film probably three
days out of the week it's where I
started my project and I think I just
love the people honestly
that's what brings me back every time I
love the answers I get I love the
interactions like I have with the people
and not too many rejections so I don't
get my heart broken too yeah the people
for sure people like you alright
what is your name Sariah what do you
hope to accomplish I have a couple of
goals I'm hoping like a goal with the
number two it is to just gain as many
followers on YouTube hopefully like 10
million that's a big goal but I just
want a big audience to share my work
with and then the more deeper goal than
that is to
hopefully share a good message and
and honestly my daily goal is to never
lose sight of that because I only have
300 subscribers right now and I find
struggles at this point sometimes and I
just like I just hope everyday that even
when it gets a little bit bigger that I
still keep the same message and it still
has the same
meaningful content hopefully yeah so
what are you looking for when you hear
people's stories
I just want answers that are real and
honest and like it could be the simplest
thing but if the person tells the story
is the most genuine way I'll put it in
the phone so I'm not looking for
anything big I'm just looking for like
three honest and the answer you could
travel to one place in the world and
that would be the last place you can
travel to me what would it be like to go
there and stay there I would honestly
just want to go wherever my mommy's if
she was wherever she is in the world and
I knew that's where I would have to
spend the rest of my life I'd go where
my mom and my sister were as long as I'm
with them like I wouldn't care
do you believe that art can change the
oh my gosh indoors yeah definitely I
think at the right person
finds the right tool the fire
and
show it to the world in the right way
yeah for the better of course yeah that
goes without saying change the world for
the better
okay so it's already recording
okay just put it on my face it's no wait
oh you're okay
yeah what's your oh gosh
[Music]